welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in Sam Raimi's spider-man two
triumphs by kicking its hero's ass tobey
maguire takes such a beating in this
film you just want to scream in
frustration with everyone else
frustration is exactly what makes
spider-man 2 my favorite Spidey film
movie that like The Dark Knight inspired
younger me to spend my adulthood
obsessively re-watch its superhero
movies which is why I was stoked a month
ago when you guys voted these movies
your top requests to re-explore so let's
dad back into spider-man 2
scene-by-scene
hell frame-by-frame for all the Easter
eggs cameos and subtle filmmaking
details that you might have missed it's
ok I missed some of these at first -
here we go the opening titles feature
comic book imagery recapping the first
film with the artwork by the great Alex
Ross some of rasa's spider-man comic art
makes subtle cameos later the police
photos and Harry Osborn's research on
spider-man and we transition from Ross's
brushstrokes of MJ's eyes to what we
think is her face but what is actually a
misdirect perfume billboard taunting
Peter Parker with unattainable love this
face bookends the film as its closing
shot the woman Peter must turn his back
to in order to be the hero the
responsibility of his great power
another visual example of Peters back
turned to MJ the flower stand where he
later buys flowers for MJ is behind him
here
next door to his new job at Jews Pizza
Pizza time comedian aasif Mandvi plays
mr. Z's cool if you actually watch this
movie slowly you see how they snuck in
another haunting MJ perfume ad on the
bus Peter nearly hits he cannot escape
her spell Show comedian Donnell Rawlings
shows up and the guy who steals a slice
of not deep-dish pizza is a Scott
Spiegel co-writer of Evil Dead 2 with
Sam Raimi he shows up in a jazz club in
the next movie god I'm sorry you had to
be there for that and despite Peters
charming greeting Pizza time future
bones star Emily Deschanel holds them to
the 29 minute guarantee
the phone number on his helmet sticker
is the real phone number for Joe's pizza
in New York and yes the address on
Bleecker Street is nearby one-77 a
Bleecker Street these sanctum sanctorum
residence of dr. strange whom according
to gender jameson exists in this movies
universe dr. strange that's pretty good
it's taken Peter gets back-to-back sacks
[Music]
you're fired
hello you're fired yeah Peter cannot
catch a break in this film and I cannot
think of a superhero movie that's so
tortures it's hero with failure after
failure in all kinds of little ways now
I'm sure in Infinity Ward they lose half
of everyone in a Dark Knight he lose
it's right raw but those losses are
balanced out by sexy wins throughout the
rest of those movies there's nothing
sexy about spider-man
- this guy's broke humiliated impotent
any when he eats out as an asterisk and
this is all Raimi showing how heroism is
pain now Peter tries to hold off selling
Jameson a Spidey photo until all right
well the picture of a rancid chicken
there's a headline food poisoning scare
sweep city it's a boot that poisoned I'm
a little nauseous yeah all right mr.
Jameson yeah Peter has to give in to
stop fake news from sparking a citywide
panic it's also cuz it's broke but you
know he tried here the second [ __ ]
Columbia students who smack him is a
cameo by Sam Raimi himself and we made
dr. Conners after his mention in the
first film Curt Connors is an amputee
and it was meant to set him up in a
future film to try to regrow his arm and
become the lizard and yeah over a year
ago some fans spotted how Peter has to
duct tape his backpack strap to keep it
all together it's not exactly
mind-blowing though because as a high
school student 2004 this is just
something we all tried to do to look
cool who's the era of whiteout messages
and hold duct-tape prom suits so weird
time now Aunt May rubs in the guilt
about Uncle Ben two years next month
says he was taken
oof taken passive voice not since that
mugger shot him but since he was taken
from me by the universe and all the
[ __ ] bad Samaritans in it what is
that he wasn't you
Peters landlord is mr. dick ovitch
ramie has always said Ditko bitch's name
was a nod to spider-man co-creator Steve
Ditko and in Peters flat the MJ photo
behind him is not one of the photos he
took of MJ on the field trip pass has
been incorrectly stated but is actually
a promo set photo of Kirsten Dunst from
the first film however you can actually
see one of the field trip photos later
pinned to his mirror the great Alfred
Molina plays dr. Otto Octavius and
Daniel Dae Kim plays his assistant now
Peter and Otto trade nerdy references
did Bernoulli sleep before he found the
curves of quickest descent actually that
can afford my high school geometry
teacher was obsessed with this line and
he explained how Peter is actually
referencing the physics of his own swing
Bernoulli proposed that the fastest way
to get from A to B could actually be a
curved motion using the forces of
gravity and then a month ago when I
talked about Tom Holland Peter applying
classroom physics and homecoming some EU
tweeted me a reddit post saying yeah
Toby did the same thing but but as the
comments of that post and my geometry
teacher correctly explained or
Bernoulli's per Kista Crone to apply
Peters web length would have to change
as he swings which it usually doesn't
it's a taut radius of a circle yet
however when I actually rewatched this
movie slowly later Peter does use the
elasticity of his web it's fluctuating
lengths due to gravity to slingshot the
Clocktower hand back at otto he has his
mentor with the physics they previously
geeked out over to punch his clock
checkmate really to be honest math was
not my strong suit I was more of a Rosie
and I was trying to explain the theory
of relativity and Rosie was trying to
explain TS Eliot TS Eliot famously ended
his 1925 poem The Hollow Men with the
wine this is the way the world ends not
with a bang but with a whimper and
during the Cold War this poem was
considered eerily prophetic for its
relevance to nuclear annihilation
similar fusion tech that spells out
octavius's doom which thankfully for the
city comes not with a bang but with a
whimper and speaking of a peel it in J's
play is Oscar Wilde's The Importance of
Being Earnest which is about a man
living a double life
the name ernest itself being a pun
about his lack of earnestness and you
probably knows how the dialogue
obviously reflects Peter and MJ
situation then you think we should
forgive them yes I mean no I hope you
have not been leading a double life
pretending to be wicked and being really
good all the time
that would be hypocrisy what did he
actually read this play this insincerity
theme doesn't stop with the guy every
character in the play is full of it and
just like how this metaphor is really
about MJ whose attraction to Peter is
really based on his mysterious unknowns
huge red flags not a deal-breaker
hmmmm now Peters late after stopping a
chasey dangles the two criminals from
the light pole right beside a chandelier
store because you know they're hanging
from the light like they're like
chandeliers and if you get it Sam Rainey
collaborator Bruce Campbell cameos again
as he snooty uh sure no one will be
seated after the doors are closed helps
maintain the illusion Ruth played the
wrestling announcer in the first film
and the restaurant hosting a third much
speculation that he was being set up as
wannabe actor Mysterio there's actually
concept art drawn out for a scrapped
fourth Raimi film that would have opened
with spider-man booking Mysterio two
years ago fans spotted that you can see
how Peter briefly considers webbing that
huh sure the real detail behind this is
that this movie's early script draft and
novelization included Peter actually
with a nut Bruce Campbell within only
making it into the play for the final
scene so we still missed it outside
there's this violin busker playing the
60s vitamin theme and the show poster
behind MJ raves Jay Fraser is especially
effective a nod to John Fraser who was
part of the team who won an Oscar for
their special effects work on the film
Peter shares an elevator with Hal sparks
phil lamarr actually auditioned for this
cameo he ended up doing an uncredited
cameo on the train now Malina nicknamed
the dock arms Larry Harry Moe and Flo
Flo was a top right one used for more
delicate functions like handling the
tritium and later
removing the sunglasses light in a cigar
and at the base of this
incredibly dangerous fusion reaction in
the middle of a city is a pool of water
now this is used probably as a coolant
for telling his future solution to the
problem later the river chronic
everything goes wrong the moment RT Vyas
invokes Icarus the power of the Sun in
the palm of my hand
okay now his handle oozes its contents
these second he tries to reassure
everyone watch zipping into the fusion
because peter distracts Otto Otto fails
to contain the biggest energy spike the
one that bends the windows and kills
Rosie
what was it you'll paper and I love
rainy shot with Rosie reflecting on the
glass right before it goes into her eye
echoed later with the reflection of
Peter in Otto's eye as that threat zips
towards him now my second favorite scene
in the movie is one rainy took months to
design doc Ock's awakening in the
hospital this is true rainy or evoking
the tree branch dragon evil dead too
rainy even includes a close-up of Ash's
iconic weapon the chainsaw and he mixes
in a solid bone snap sound effective
when the arm grabs the surgeons leg and
one of the surgeons is a cameo by horror
director John Landis and one of my
favorite details that I've only caught
by actually re watching this again in
slow motion when the arms are docile
under Otto's controlled their claw
lights are white but when they are in
controlling and evil the lights go red
and we see this again later when he
regains control of them in the final act
hey you may be able to relate with Peter
Parker's frustrations in today's era
with issues like the content you
normally consume on the internet being
blocked from your reach or hackers and
scammers stealing your info well
expressvpn is your solution thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video
expressvpn is a virtual private network
that encrypts your data to keep it from
being stolen or tracked and can grant
you access to blocked content many
websites and services are blocked in
different parts of the world in some
countries censor websites and don't let
you surf freely like netflix in the UK
as content us Netflix doesn't have vice
versa there are countries I won't let
you use Netflix imagine and some things
are
more expensive online depending on where
you live like airline tickets how could
they do this to us
expressvpn allows you to reroute your
connection to a server in a country of
your choice making geo restrictions a
thing of the past
expressvpn is also helpful for
preventing your online data from being
stolen or monitored without your
knowledge which to me is the equivalent
of throwing a freaking car at me through
the window expressvpn servers operate at
the fastest speeds they have 24/7
customer support and it's super easy to
use just fire up the app and connect
with just one click
it's a top-rated VPN provider rated
number one by tech radar
CNET and many more find out how you can
get three months free by clicking the
link in the description box below
expressvpn comm slash new rockstars
again that's expressvpn the.com slash
new rock stars dr. octopus is coined by
jameson well actually by kaufman head
rainy Sam's brother
and again gotta mention dr. strange was
taken dr. strange that's pretty good
it's taken meaning he's this in this
film universe which has proven more than
a bit ironic now that Sam Raimi is
directing dr. strange too for Marvel and
a pause in here so JK Simmons can make
you smile could you pay me in advance
Auto laments and these monstrous things
should be at the bottom of the river
along with me from flow and gradual fade
from white to red signals the arms take
over from here forward when they turn
white again at the end Auto will resume
with this suicidal thinking drowning
himself in his little monsters in the
bottom of the river joel mchale cam here
this is a loan officer oh but I'm giving
piano lessons again you are I'd love
that cement to kick Peter butt kicks
Joel but Mays piano teaching might
justify why Peter was a randomly good at
piano in the third movie if anything
could justify that madness Otto's climb
up the wall has a rhythmic pacing to it
that's because during production Molina
was performing at stevia in the revival
of fiddler on the roof if he would hum
under his breath that stompy song for a
rich bone and the puppeteers would sink
the arm walk with a song
a little dumb I play piano
Stanly cameos pause I'm gonna safety
then in the worst gig ever Peter leaves
the lens cap on come on and it keeps
missing out on the last a poor cocktail
a gag that the high society movie The
Great Gatsby would later call back and
Jay gets engaged to Jameson's astronaut
son John becomes man wolf in the comics
and after his powers glitched out again
the Daily Bugle he reads includes a
blurb about chronic back pain maybe a
nod to Tobey Maguire's back pain that
almost caused him to sit out this movie
some believe that the later joke
could've been a nod to that my back but
the writers claim that this joke was
already written in the script for Toby's
issues came out Peter drink chats with
Uncle Ben's ghost under Peters zip-up
you can actually see he is wearing the
red top of his wrestler costume Peter
says any junks his suit with this frame
pulled directly from the famous amazing
spider-man issue 50 spider-man no more
this title also shows up on a daily
bugle front page now Peter fixes the
wheel of his moped that got crushed
earlier in the film but just like that
wheel flies out the window so do his
hopes for normalcy
now the bugle blames him for rising
crime and he watches a guy get jumped
originally in the script this victim was
gonna be the man who recovered and sold
Jameson the suit a more direct
consequence of Peters retirement now as
I pointed out my breakdown of the
previous film the guy who points Peter
to the burning building is the same guy
from the bridge and again despite this
apparent victory Peter still cannot win
some poor soul got trapped on the fourth
floor
but Peter finally gives in to this
heroism is pain idea inspired by Aunt
May's swallowing her pride and selling
her house sometimes we have to be steady
and give up the thing we want the most
now it's pretty obvious that Maine knows
Peter is spider-man which I suspect is
why she got the kid next door to help
her pack up her house despite his baby
arm she's guilting Peter with a child's
disappointment Otto gets Peters
attention by throwing a car at him just
as the face of rosey was reflected on
the glass before her death MJ's kissy
face is reflected briefly on Peters
lenses seconds before her near death
these are the frames Peter literally
detaches from justice he lets go of his
dreams of love with MJ regaining his
heroic vision both literally and
metaphorically this fist close-up was an
image focused on by Alex Ross's opening
arts ring in peter full circle with the
rediscovery of his power
the bugle reports he's back but no photo
on the front page since they wouldn't
have any recent photos of spider-man
being used also the blurb up in the
corner reads MTA insider concerned over
ageing El train safety reflecting the
safety concerns for the following el
train sequence now New York did not have
an L in operation so they shot all of
this on Chicago's loop this train fight
is one of the best sequences in the
superhero genre Raimi breaks it all up
into three acts just like a short film
that works on its own act 1 Peter versus
Otto on the clock tower a ticking clock
as meta for act 2 Peter versus Otto on
the train both victims of destiny
together and in an act 3 Peter alone
versus a train man versus time and
destiny itself it opens with Peters
heroic swings into action with Raimi
pulls out to reveal framed within the
deadly threat waiting for him the
sunglasses lens of Doc Ock no cool
moment without an asterisk of how he's
about to die I love this kind of shot
Robert Zemeckis actually used a similar
tracking shot mirror reframe and contact
the very cool way of shifting subjective
point of view to the target of the
action when they tumble down onto the
train Otto's arms cushion his body
during the rule
ramie also smartly cuts often to the
passengers including the classic woman
with a baby and briefly Peter and Otto
go inside the car so that a minute later
when Otto starts playing 500 with people
this doesn't come out of nowhere it
happens after Peter's empathy has been
triggered now this train stop gives us
some epic Tobi faces which yes the memes
are hilarious but without the ironic
detachment that hijacked us as we got
older this is a beaten-down hero ripping
onto the one thing he has left after
having to let go of everything else he
once all of this suffering has boiled
over and now Toby is venting pure
cathartic rage it's earned and I love it
we had some good Christ pose imagery and
the kids who returned his mask are
cameos by Toby's half-brothers after
Robbie the editor may these passengers
and then of course Harry in MJ Peters
precious anonymity in this film is
stripped away from him when many things
he has to let go of Otto wraps Peter in
barbed wire echoing the moment Peter
briefly saw a spiderweb strung up in a
barbed wire coil in the first film
his whole webby world surrounded by a
ring of death behind Harry's prop
tonight is a framed photo with Norman
I assume this is Harry's revenge table
Peter ends up flipping Otto by repeating
Aunt May's wisdom Oh sometimes to do
what's right even now dreams and Peter
can finally deliver this with sincere
honest heartbreak because in this moment
he is really talking about his dream
with MJ he truly gets the importance of
being earnest now along with John
Jameson I just realized that Jay Jonah
and Bachmann arrived with the cops -
this guy cannot pass up an opportunity
to insert himself in the story in order
to sell more papers Norman Osborn
returns inside Harry's mind now a little
detail I spotted by going through this
frame by frame when he throws the dagger
through the mirror it briefly switches
from Norman to his own reflection and
then back to Norman who looks pain as
the glass breaks two generations of
Green Goblin becoming one in the same
and then after Harry finds the Goblin
cave I think most of us got that green
bow tie he shows up wearing at the
wedding that's okay if this was a poncho
for you it's just kind of like baked in
for me since
spent the whole summer of Oh for
rewatching this with like prisoner of
azkaban but I love this ending it
parallels the ambient of the graduates
runaway bride fleeing the church to be
with the scrap you dope
but the graduates ending is brilliant
because it is not a fairy tale ending
it's a bittersweet hello darkness bus
ride where the young couple catches
their breath and realizes wait crap what
did we just do what now
MJ here mix these same realization she
teases fairy tale ending with her comics
pet name okay I'm tanked and for a
second we think it's gonna end with
another golden sunset heroic swing pass
and Stars and Stripes just like the
first movie did but nope
rainy cuts back to MJ with dark tones
and an ominous fade to black
it's a bittersweet graduate hello
darkness ending echoing the opening shot
of MJ as the love that Peter would never
have time for reminding us that
spider-man two is not a story about
heroes win but how heroism is pain and
every heroic victory is underscored by a
dark consequence as you could see
smarter man too was one of the all-time
best superhero films filled with awesome
attention to detail that other recap was
just gloss over because it's not the
precious and see you and I am so
thrilled that you guys asked me a month
ago to break down a movie that was such
a big part of my youth and if you were
there with me in the summer of 2004 I
hope this brought back some memories for
you feel free to share those in the
comments instead of you know like a
snart pain that I missed some [ __ ]
Ford Focus Easter Egg someone pointed
out to you without really understanding
the actual movie detail is join our
future classic movie watch along Jean
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me on instagram at EA vaz follow new
rock stars and subscribe for more
in-depth movie breakdowns Godspeed
[Music]